there's been quite a genesis to Donald
Trump's position about what he knew and
what his involvement was related to this
entire stormy Daniels scandal at one
point it was he knew nothing about
anything at another point it's he had no
idea that there was money paid to her at
another point the position was he never
paid back Michael Cohen and then Rudy
Giuliani's took basically all sides of
that issue and then backed it off and
said he actually misspoke
we now have effectively a formal
acknowledgement because of a disclosure
that Donald Trump has put out that he
repaid Michael Cohen somewhere between
one hundred thousand and two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in expenses
incurred during the 2016 presidential
election and the disclosure form that's
been filed by Donald Trump doesn't say
exactly what those repayments were for
but of course the timing and the amount
suggests that it would be for the
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
hush money that we know Donald Trump's
lawyer paid to adult film actress stormy
Daniels through his shell consultancy
company called essential consultants so
that she wouldn't talk about her affair
with Donald Trump shortly before the
2016 election and as usual everything is
it is a distortion some would call them
lies I call them lives
Trump's people even in explaining the
disclosure are trying to paint a
completely inaccurate picture saying
that Donald Trump didn't even have to
make this disclosure but he's such a
good guy and he's so into being
transparent that he chose out of his
good will to make this financial
disclosure even that's not true the
office of government ethics said ya know
this is required information that Donald
Trump actually has to report and
hilariously this specific information
was put in a footnote right the idea
that your actions reflect some
overarching desire for a high level of
transparency are not exactly evidenced
by a footnote which is just laughable at
its face and none of this is shocking
right I mean from day one it was clear
that Donald Trump repaid my
Koen the billionaire Donald Trump
obviously paid back the lawyer that
reportedly needed to mortgage his house
or his condo or whatever it was to get
this hundred and thirty thousand dollars
to give to stormy Daniels so the
question for me is when will the
trumpets hold Trump accountable either
for his lies or the immorality of his
actions and by the immorality I don't
mean the affair I don't care about
Trump's affair with stormy Daniels I
mean the bullying of stormy Daniels and
the answer is they're never gonna hold
them accountable for it so all we really
learn from this is I guess nothing right
I mean we confirmed a few things we
confirmed number one that they've been
lying all along about the repayment
because they've told us multiple
versions about it that can't all be true
number two we confirmed that Trump did
pay back the money number three we've
confirmed that there are still legal
questions about the repayment as
campaign spending and I will we ever
actually get to the bottom of that I
don't know and number four we learned
that Trump has likely been lying when he
said he never knew anything at any point
about any of this stuff and as a side
note the disclosures also claimed and
this is actually pretty interesting to
me
the disclosures Trump filed yesterday
also claimed that revenue at mar-a-lago
is down ten percent compared to last
year a lot of charity events have
canceled their scheduled events at
mar-a-lago and also Trump's Doral Golf
Resort is down about fourteen percent in
revenue so that that's notable because
we knew that there was even though the
Trump businesses continue to make a ton
of money the presidency has not been
great for some of the businesses
although presumably really good for
stuff like foreign diplomats staying at
Trump's Washington DC hotel and you can
tell that they are worried about the
possible legal implications here because
the trumpets are now saying stuff like
Michael avenatti is way outside of his
scope as the lawyer of stormy Daniels
he's just a lawyer he can look into
whatever he wants he can tweet about
whatever he wants right he's not
restricted in what he can do and there
are actually trumpets who after Michael
avenatti tweeted about we know that the
money was paid back by Trump
know about the shell company we know
about all the stuff they were saying the
problem is avenatti who's supposed to
just be representing stormy Daniels
tweeting about it that's not the problem
this is like with leaks where if the
Republicans like the content of the
leaks they don't care how we learn about
it if they don't like the content of the
leaks the problem is that there was a
leak and that's really what we should be
focused on avenatti can do whatever the
hell he wants yeah and one of those
committed trumpets is Rudy Giuliani
who's back in the media circuit now
saying that the president can't be
indicted and apparently he was told that
by the Muller team oh yeah that's for a
different issue that's for the Russia
stuff but hey I mean with the campaign
finance violations that could be here
here Trump could be in trouble for like
accessory after the fact or
co-conspiracy there there could be some
charges there conceivably although I
still think it's unlikely we ever see an
indictment of Trump like I believe that
the president can be indicted but I
believe that the president will not be
indicted and whether Rudy Giuliani has
any clue what he's talking about at this
point is an outstanding question mark I
guess I would say